reminds me we went to like a supermarket
here in l.a yesterday and they were
selling raw milk oh yeah do you know
about the supermarket i don't know
there's a supermarket called heroin it
sounds like oh that's the like rich
white yeah my friend told me about it
and we just randomly found it yesterday
yeah so i went in
they were selling
a gallon of milk yeah
called raw milk yeah for twenty dollars
and that milk is is is not treated for
any bacteria it's what makes it raw yeah
so it's just unpasteurized milk just
unpasteurized milk yeah yeah that's so
you're basically just like paying more
for a more dangerous product yeah i
think like people are just so obsessed
with like natural hair like that to the
point of like dangerous cause that's a
whole thing of like fresh water yeah
yeah it's like yeah unfortunately you
have to get water that has not been like
touched by anyone else yeah
why do i have to do that oh yeah
that's [ __ ] water yeah you got the
hydrogen infused yeah i got like
hydrogen infused water it didn't even
come in a bottle it came in like a bag a
bag like an astronaut bag that doesn't
make any sense
it's just water it's still water
because you can't add an atom it's it's
no water i don't even know what it meant
you know
it's it's really bizarre seeing the
whole because i feel like this wasn't
here when i came here like 2018 19. the
whole like alkaline water trend there's
a lot of that yeah it's like why is this
a thing they just like to [ __ ] with the
ph and it makes a whole new product it's
like we i think humans have existed
pretty good with this water thing for
like yeah we've been doing it for a long
time like some other stuff that i could
i feel like there's other technological
advancements we could be focusing on but
i added some [ __ ] acid in my water
yeah yeah and now i'm like [ __ ] plain
of existence like floating like it's
like what do you expect like i don't
this is such a bizarre thing i do i
don't know and it feels weird how like
it's like do you think i'm dumb enough
to buy this and apparently it's like yes
oh actually yeah in fact our entire
business is built around your stupidity
yeah yeah like your thing didn't even
[ __ ] taste good yeah
your thing tasted like like sparkling
water that had like it's flat
water don't fly like you know how like
flat soda taste it tastes disgusting i
never have tasted flat sparkling water
before that's exactly what it tasted
like but it's like it feels like a
system-wide distrust in just how stuff
is made here yeah which is reasonable
there's a lot of bad stuff here there's
a lot of like bad poorly produced food
oh yeah gotcha yeah yeah that's probably
where it stems from yeah it's like a
scary health conscious thing yeah yeah
would you say is the best american food
then
i mean american food has got like a
bunch of other countries kind of stolen
yeah yeah yeah you're [ __ ]
every other country mocking
still got it here it's the thing is
still i can go to korean barbecue
we can do that in the uk you just pay a
lot of money yeah and it takes worse uh
probably
they just you know the uk is just
catching on they're like ramen that's
like holy [ __ ] we could put spices for
our food
we've been trading this [ __ ] for
hundreds of years and we never thought
to put it in the food
whoa
america's like bro what if we put sugar
in this
like this is salt like yeah add sugar
they should add more sugar add sugar add
oil
as much as the last guy dude [ __ ]
sukiyaki is amazing is the same idea
right i do like sukiyaki
he's like you gotta eat the cow
intestine and i'm like this [ __ ] tastes
bad
i didn't want to be that guy yeah yeah
yeah the blood blood blood tofu was good
though yeah he's made he's made me eat a
lot of questionable [ __ ] yeah maybe like
duck brains yeah that was interesting it
all tastes good though but joey's you're
the guy who eats everything though right
yeah was there anything that didn't fit
your taste palette no it was all good it
was all good i had like pigs intestines
i had ducks brains it was all it all
slapped
uh
it's like it's like salted and fermented
mud oh no i'm just like it's like
fermented it kind of tastes like if you
got a piece of like uh if you got a
sardine and you kind of put it in the
dirt yeah and then just left it there
for a day and you came back the next day
you picked it up and you ate it oh
that's kind of what it tastes like these
[ __ ] just want to keep fermenting
everything it's just too much fermenting
going
just stop fermenting
fermentation who saw a fish and was like
nah dude i i just want this to be
[ __ ] 20 times smelly like just eat
the fish
you know what it doesn't smell enough
like puke you know
i really want to really want to feel
like throwing up
most of the fish in japan even i don't i
don't question it i'm like don't tell me
what this is because if you tell me what
you did to this fish
but you eat it and you're like that's
pretty good and then like by the way uh
yeah we we just left this in piss for
five times
that's the dish you're like all right
okay i wonder what the tangy taste was
yeah yeah i've i'd finaze you once which
is like where they take a piece of uh
white fish or something and they ferment
it for 10 years
like wine oh i think i saw that on like
an idiot abroad or something yeah yeah
for her video and i was like i'll try it
because apparently like one of the
reviews was like when you eat it it
feels like you're being electrocuted in
your mouth and i'm like is that a good
thing
it's not even like food at that point oh
yeah yeah
eating matter is
it's a branding thing to like look what
we have guys because every every place
in japan has to be famous for something
yeah yeah it's really like important for
some reason like whenever you talk to
anyone you're like i went to this place
like did you try the x famous thing in
there yeah yeah and most the time it's
like
it's like no different they're like yeah
their rice is the best amelia always
does this as well every prefecture says
that they have the best rice but
everyone knows it all tastes the same
yeah and almost every prefecture has
like yes melanie i did just say we just
called you out every prefecture has a
specialty fruit as well it seems like
yeah and it's like sometimes it just
tastes good actually sometimes it tastes
good but like fruit in japan just tastes
good in general i think yeah
yeah yeah hokkaido is like where the
best foods at the big island at the top
yeah yeah [ __ ] amazing yeah yeah
they've somehow perfected food i don't
know how they did it
do you like it when they like kill the
thing in front of you is that like i
think it's probably yeah i love that
yeah
i i didn't want to assume that was your
energy but i guess that's
if they kill it in front of me it's
going to just be amazing
yeah there's places where they'll do
that with the crab where they bring it
out oh okay that's you want this one
this one
like
yeah and you're [ __ ] they'll [ __ ]
boil it in front of you
yeah that's good i don't even want to
eat it i just wanted to see you guys
that much okay
you don't need to prepare it all right
it's like chicken
like police giant [ __ ] crabs the
spider crabs are [ __ ] massive
and you know i was at this place and you
order a crab whatever and i didn't
expect it but they like this this tiny
woman brings out on on like just a
normal serving tray brings out this
giant crab for you to look at she's like
is this okay it's like what what would i
have said yes
like i would like one that is not this
one bigger yeah you're big more bring
out a bigger one i want to see you
struggle did
it's like trying to wiggle and you're
like oh yeah that one that one that
one's good
when they bring out like the wine for
you to try so you just like swirl it
you're like yeah
no
i've never seen someone say no this wine
is not good enough
especially when you're like british
you're like this is too awkward i can't
say no yeah i can't be like no also
they've uncorked the wine right so yeah
i feel i'd feel too bad yeah i've i've
been to a dinner with someone like that
in my head i'm just like you dig it
so what happens when you say no they
bring you they just bring you out and
you bring out another one oh you can
just sell of the same wine or different
different like different that they think
would match better to your taste buds
and i'm just like dude
like you [ __ ] know the difference
yeah you're kind of just trying to be
like yeah i know the difference between
these yeah
yeah
but like with beer you can just like you
can just pour a little bit you know but
if you uncork a wine it ruins an entire
bottle of wine yeah exactly you know
they can't serve that someone else no
yeah
have you ever been to like like an ice
cream place and you just have like that
one guy who just tries every [ __ ]
flavor yeah there's a lemon i think it's
four is it four three three
i think they would let you try
everything yeah that's nice well i mean
a limit culturally i think they'll try
to let you trust but like i feel bad
after yeah
yeah i i mean is is the vanilla really
gonna taste
like i don't understand like yeah okay
sometimes they have some really obscure
flavors you're like okay i do want to
try that but like when people like can i
try the uh the chocolate ice cream it's
like
yeah yeah you know what chocolate tastes
like you've never had chocolate before
like
it can't taste that different yeah i
refuse to believe this chocolate can
taste so different to the point where
you have to taste it and be that guy who
makes the line weight like yeah come on
yeah again they just want to be the
[ __ ] that's all it is i don't know
i don't i feel bad at costco asking for
the samples
i don't even do that yeah i didn't know
you could do that what
that's the whole point oh oh you mean
the side samples yeah oh no
i never go to those when in japan the
costco they don't really have that many
samples yeah yeah and uh i took a diet
and emily to the costco and they were
like where's the samples and i was like
uh i mean there's some and he was like i
just ate i just had four shots of red
bull i'm like why
it was free it's a sample it's a sample
it's free i'm like you know what red
bull tastes like you don't need a sample
of rice i always feel bad i never go for
the samples because i always feel bad
because 99 times out of 100 it's
something that i know i don't need yeah
so it's like it's it's taking the sample
and you just like pretending to be like
yeah this is very nice and then just
their eyesight of like you're gonna buy
it right
and i don't have the heart to be like
no
i don't want to see the disappointment
in their eyes when they're just like oh
okay he's like offended he was like is
grapes the only thing they have to
sample what about like the good food
i
there are two types of costco customers
yeah
what do you want them to do like the
first food they have yeah right the hot
dog's a dollar fifty you don't get that
oh yeah it's so good oh the costco 300
yen is it in japan though yeah throw it
again they mug you off dude 1.50 damn
yeah
in this economy dude
[ __ ] well they're like they're like in
america like it has to say a dollar
fifty the rest of all their [ __ ]
raise the price yeah yeah [ __ ] lucky
but like you can get like whole fishes
like uh like giant salmon cuts and stuff
in japan really fresh fish really fresh
sushi yeah sushi can't [ __ ] talk yeah
it's really good stuff
you should go check it out when you're
there your costco membership works
worldwide really yeah yeah yeah that's
funny as far as yeah it's funny when i
moved to japan i thought and i was
asking like locals where to go i thought
people would like be recommending like
you know really local sports underground
places cool restaurants and literally
nine times out of ten people like yo
you've been to the costco here no you've
been
i don't like the food at ikea
do you like the food i like you i mean
meatballs
okay it's a [ __ ] meatball like how i
mean you can't really [ __ ] up a meatball
you're shopping
you can't shop andy it's an experience
yeah i love how the we noticed yesterday
uh we were
pushing the card around i was going to
say trolley yeah yeah that's like glad
you caught yourself yeah
oh yeah
uh it had a cup holder
oh yeah i think it's like god [ __ ]
bless america yeah you can't i can't put
my drink down for like 10 minutes like i
gotta make sure i'm [ __ ]
sipping on my big gulp
what if i have a [ __ ] soda that i
don't need i'm drinking man i don't want
to leave that in the car
everyone always has a starbucks at all
times i've noticed oh yeah starbucks is
real big you ever look up a map of
starbucks this year it's crazy it's just
always drinking the starbucks yeah yeah
i can't put it down yeah gotta i gotta i
gotta go to the store pick up my
groceries while drinking a starbucks
yeah sometimes they have starbucks in
the grocery store they they had that
yeah yeah yeah what the [ __ ] yeah quite
good i mean yeah i'm not really a big
fan of that's they're uh i like that
they have food though
it's like a decent you should check out
japan yeah it's it's i think starbucks
is [ __ ] everywhere else i'll be going a
lot of places in japan yeah yeah the
starbucks in japan it's like an
amusement park is it good though because
i think in japan yeah yeah it's [ __ ]
good i think i don't like it i i think
it's good but i also part of me is just
like is it just because most other
coffee places in japan suck yeah you
know there's that but i think just like
time we were at this place and he was
like uh chris was like
tell us about tallies he was like i'm
telling you they have the best beef
stroganoff i've ever
i was like
i was like really yeah and we both
ordered it and we were eating it you
know when you you're like telling your
friend like dude this is amazing and
then and then you eat it again and
you're like
you said that crippling embarrassment of
like
yeah it's like when you say this such a
funny youtube video yeah yeah yeah yeah
he was just ahead of never cause he's
such a he'll he's so reluctant to admit
he's wrong yeah yeah yeah so he was like
it's not as good
i'm not as good as the last time i was
like he was like could we go eat
something else
at least he didn't do the thing where
it's like well it's because we're in
this tully like the other tallies i i
think he he was like knew i was not
gonna i was gonna be like [ __ ] off
absolutely not this is a chain there's
no [ __ ] way this isn't standardized
this tastes like [ __ ] because they're so
skimpy with beef sometimes and beef
dishes make sense here yeah because they
don't have as much like three pieces of
beef it was it was it was barely a
stroganoff it was a sauce with mash yeah
i don't know what the [ __ ] it was it was
[ __ ] it was god what is your go-to
convenience store meal like okay when i
was in japan the first time or i only
went to convenience stores and the
chicken was the best [ __ ] thing it
was the best convenience store chicken i
ever had
which convenience store did you go to
which one yeah which one it's important
family mart 7-eleven or so i think it
was 7-eleven
that's my favorite one yeah yeah up
their game on like everything and now i
think lawsons are just the best for
everything what what do they have other
than chicken and two other fried items
it was like uh i highly recommend uh the
beef bowl there i i [ __ ] love the
beef bowls in any of the places oh yeah
a lot of the dishes you can just take to
them ask them they'll be like they'll
ask you something just say hi yeah yeah
and then they'll warm it up yeah so
they're warming up on the spot so you
can eat it like i know it's a little
controversial i think
uh 7-eleven hawaii is better than the
seven one in japan
really i don't know about that but i
just assume that's a big deal you should
go next time well i put 7-eleven in like
singapore is crazy too yeah sure seven
live in singapore is lit yeah i think
like honestly it's because the japanese
convenience store standards are so high
but 7-eleven in thailand [ __ ] slaps
yeah like oh yeah honestly 7-eleven just
slaps worldwide yeah yeah
yeah
holy [ __ ]
yeah we got lucky with like the asian
influence for the convenience stores
it's so good you got like so much local
food like spanish bees and like
non-stuffed beef bowls and yeah yeah but
like but when i went to hawaii like
because i was on oahu yeah and i went
into a mall yeah and like 50 of the
stores are just run by japanese people
oh yeah oahu like i think it's the most
japanese yeah like i i went into the
mall they had like billboard ads in
japanese yeah like not even in english
and i'm like i thought i was in a mall
in tokyo somewhere yeah and you can just
like paste it in yen and i'm like what
yeah you can you can go into some stores
and maybe it was just that department i
don't know but like i went into this
department store and like 50 of the
stores you can go into that are owned by
japanese people you can pay in yemen
cherokee probably yeah i don't know yeah
yeah it's a it's i think that's the
highest demographic on oahu yeah yeah
that's crazy just like i was walking
around oahu and it's just like every
second person was speaking japanese yeah
yeah that's yeah
i like this lady bumped into me this
like old white lady and she like without
even looking she said that swimming
i was like
i'm from here
she's so used to it yeah yeah it's crazy
dude yeah at the conbinis i always go
for the sandwiches yeah yeah the
sandwiches are really [ __ ] good like
yeah tuna and mayo ones from uh the tuna
and egg ones and lawsons are my one of
my favorites okay
mini stock they have ice cream they're
they're famous for soft serve yeah
that's really good he stops off so yeah
but but i'm trying not to gain weight
right so when you live in japan it's a
different beast yeah it's like you can't
you can't eat there like you're on
vacation yeah right right right and like
the food there you need to be
responsible about it right right and and
the food is healthy for you but the
actual like japan food laws are actually
really lacks like you can put whatever
the [ __ ] you want in a lot of this food
and they have a lot of adjectives and
stuff and uh adjectives [ __ ]
additives
a lot of additives in a lot of food a
lot of stuff that's banned elsewhere in
japanese food fun um yep so
it is um there are a lot of stuff that
is super unhealthy for you so you do
have to be careful yeah being like it
being easy to lose weight in japan is
like a misnomer because one food is
amazing there so you're just gonna wanna
eat like i'm gonna eat a [ __ ] ton of it
yeah yeah yeah the portion sizes may be
small but then you end up having six
meals a day yeah it's just like
it doesn't matter yeah everyone thinks
i'm gonna be surrounded by fish it's
very easy to avoid fish yeah you don't
want to eat fish it's super easy yeah
yeah thank god so uh yeah whatever you
whatever you like there's more i feel
there's more meat based places than
fish-based places oh god yeah yeah
but also there's more fish-based places
than pretty much everywhere else in the
world oh yeah of course it's just a lot
of food that's why being vegetarian and
vegan in japan is like so [ __ ] hard
yeah oh vegan
i mean it's getting better like there's
a lot more vegan places in tokyo now but
i remember like five years ago there was
like two yeah i've never seen a
gluten-free option that's just never
been a thing either
yeah they're like you're gluten free for
the cycle yeah it's just good
they're like
you know we're not like going for
natural selection here you know
you want the cream of the grass
lactose intolerant just tolerate it yeah
just tolerate it just shoot yourself